we hope you find the evening informative
and helpful and in fact it's just worth
noting that each of our panelists
tonight is either a client to our act
program or through our public management
programs board fellows we're going to
have all the panels starting with me
speak for about 10 minutes just sharing
sort of their top insights on what being
an effective nonprofit board and board
member is both from the board members
perspective and in Jackie's case also
from the executive directors view
we're also after that and before
question and ancing going to try
something we haven't done before which
is on your seats you'll see a very short
page and a half case and so after we all
speak we're gonna ask you to amongst
yourselves just three or four of you
talk about what you're going to do with
the deadwood case and then we'll leave
hopefully a healthy time to to answer
questions either about the case or
questions of general interest let me
just begin with what I think of is the
nine attributes of successful nonprofit
boards we gave you a much longer report
with it we did it McKinsey here I'll try
to be more pithy and to the point
let me just read the nine attributes and
then I'll talk very briefly about two or
three in terms of missions and goals I
think a nonprofit boards and successful
above all has an ambitious mission which
is well and clearly identified it has
intermediate goals which are directly
related to the identified mission and
the board's role and responsibilities in
achieving that mission is explicit and
it's well understood in terms of
structure and organization and
composition good boards have a small
group of committed and cohesive leaders
they have the appropriate composition to
provide the necessary skills financial
means and perspective the three w's if
you will of work wealth and wisdom and
they have a well-defined and understood
structure for addressing the key tasks
of the board
in terms of governance processes good
nonprofit boards have a process for
interacting on important issues that
ensures that the right capabilities of
the Lord are brought to bear on those
issues they have a process that ensures
that board members view their time as
well spent and a process to engage board
members in the substance of the
organization now you probably notice
immediately that my nine attributes are
more principles than rules and on things
that nonprofit governance many people in
the first instance want a hard fast set
of rules and I try to avoid those rules
for one very good reason I think which
is you give me a rule and I'll show you
a non-profit board which obeys it and is
not very effective and I'll show you a
non-profit board that disobeys it and is
very effective so I rely much more on
general principles so let me just talk
about two or three that I think perhaps
are the most important
the old Sicilian axiom is that a fish
rots with his head and nonprofits tend
to rot from a mission statement and a
board that's not committed to it and not
energized by it my class has just
finished an exercise where they all went
through and analyzed mission statements
and as happens every year 2/3 or 3/4
discover that the mission statement as
reported is either not really the
mission statement or the mission of the
organization is different than the
mission statement or key stakeholders
including the board members are unaware
of what the mission of the organization
really is and it's incumbent upon any
board particularly in organizations that
have been around for a while that they
go through some kind of exercise on a
regular basis that the board of the day
gets to take that mission in its own
heart and its own soul and become
energized by the mission of that
organization I think the leading cause
of boards that are not effective in the
first instance are that they don't
understand and embrace the mission of
the organization that they're involved
in probably the most often asked
question about rules is how big should
my
on profit board B and the answer is
thirteen actually I don't have a hard
and fast rule I've seen lots of nice
tightly knit small boards that don't
work very well and I've actually been on
boards of 85 people that work very
effectively my rule of thumb is that a
board can be as large as such that it
allows no more than 10 or 15% of the
board members to be inactive if you can
have a large board with very active
board members in development in the
organization itself and volunteering in
committee work there are lots of very
well accepted structures their
committees and long-range planning
processes that you keep many many board
members involved in the end these things
tend to just follow the rules of small
group dynamics
and if you have a board of 15 people
you'll be very lucky indeed if you have
three or four board members who are
truly committed to that organization and
devoting a lot of time and if you have a
board of 60 or 70 you might have 12 or
15 but I don't think board size in and
of itself is something you can have a
hard and fast rule about the last
attribute I'll call attention to is
engaging the board and what I call the
thing itself it's remarkable how many
boards particularly some that people
think are very well-written they go to
the hour and a half board meeting and it
just goes right through the agenda and
one thing is for sure is the staff is
going to make sure that the board hears
everything it wants to hear and has very
little time to engage in open discussion
and at the same time very often you'll
see boards that spend very little time
on the thing itself and I would argue
very strongly that boards for nonprofits
if it's a childcare nonprofit that the
board has to have regular exposure to
child care if it's a symphony nonprofit
it needs to have regular exposure to
Symphony musicians and musicians and
directors if it's an art nonprofit it
should be art whatever else it is those
of us who serve on nonprofits serve
primary
early out of passion and interest in the
organization and we expect through the
board processes to be given regular
opportunities to engage with the thing
itself so I'll leave it right there and
turn it over to Susan Ford Dorsey thank
you it really is a great pleasure to be
here today as bill said I currently
serve on a number of boards from health
care to my son's elementary school to
the Monterey Bay Aquarium and each one
of those is is very different and over
the past 15 years I've had the pleasure
of serving on a few other boards so I
feel like I've got some experience to
share about some of the size and some of
the the qualities that make a board
function and some of the qualities that
make a board sort of dysfunctional
I'm also on a corporate board so I kind
of have the the perspective of that as
well I also had the pleasure of serving
with two of the Stanford board fellows
one with Children's Health Council and
the other recently on the Monterey Bay
Aquarium and I can say in both instances
that they really added a great deal to
to the board of that sort of fresh
perspective was very important for all
of us okay so the three most important
things that I think a board can do and
what makes a board highly functional as
opposed to too dysfunctional the first
is to to focus on what's important now
that sounds XE o matic however it is
amazing how many boards do get mired
down in the details and as bill
mentioned sort of what the staff wants
to present and doesn't really focus on
in fact what is its important work the
first thing and the most important thing
a board can do is hire and fire the CEO
if the CEO is strong then that makes the
organization strong obviously and it is
it is the single most important thing
that a board and a big responsibility
that the board has the second thing is
to focus on the key indicators in an
organization every organization is
different but I remember a few years ago
going to a board trainee or governance
training and the professor was talking
about
creating sort of a dashboard if you will
for each organization that every board
member knows what these five or six
really important indicators are of the
health of the organization whether it's
you know enrollment if it's a school the
gas gauge could be you know the the
fundraising dollars you know the
operating expenses can be the
speedometer whatever whatever it seems
to be the most logical sort of way for
the board in the snapshot to get the
best view of how the organization is
doing that quarter that month compared
to last year those things and though
that's the responsibility really of the
CEO and the senior staff to try to
figure out what this board needs to know
so that when things start going south or
improving that they're able to have that
to have that perspective the other thing
is to be strategic that the opposite of
that I guess is getting mired down in
the micromanagement but it's the board
is the one that is supposed to look down
at an organization and to keep that that
big perspective so that you can look at
trends you can think of the literature
in terms of what how this organization
compares to its peers to what's
happening in the industry you know the
if it's a school that depends upon state
funding and state funding is being
decreased then that's likely to continue
and what is the impact on the services
going to be so we it's the board's
responsibility to think about what is
going to drive this organization several
years down the road and every meeting
should have a purpose
it's it's remarkable to me how many
people you know attend board meetings
and you sit there and the reports are
read are read to you after you've course
already read them if you've prepared for
the meeting and that that's not helpful
I mean everybody goes away and then
everybody checks that out their list of
things that they've done but it's it
doesn't move the organization forward
when I chair I like to think of every
meeting as having a purpose
and saying it's very beginning at the
end of this meeting we will accomplish
the following or today we are going to
hear about whatever the sort of program
elements are and from some the providers
as bill was talking about either from
the musicians or the teachers or whoever
it happens to be that gives you a good
perspective but it's really important to
understand what decisions need to be
made and how those decisions are going
to be made okay so that's number one
focus on what really is important and
what is the appropriate board role the
second thing that I think is really
important is to provide that the board
should be a forum for the CEO to dream
to float trial balloons to try out
different ideas to talk about greatest
fears that sort of thing it really
should should be a a sounding board and
they should feel free to do that there's
oftentimes a tension that exists between
the CEO and the board as in I shouldn't
tell the board fist cuz they'll think
I'm doing a bad job they'll think the
organization's in trouble on and on but
that relationship is really really
important so the CEO can feel supported
in thinking beyond the day-to-day
organizational issues and then the third
thing I would say is to as a board
member if you decide to go on a board in
addition to being hopefully passionate
about that that's the subject matter of
the organization that you also are
willing to lend your expertise again
that sounds like a no-brainer but I'm
struck by how many times I've heard
people say gee I'm really I want to go
on this board because I want to learn
about music or art which is valid that's
fair that's it's a great way to do it
but if it's like an accountant they
might say I don't really want to be on
the Finance Committee I want to try you
know something else
well the reason you're asked to
participate on a board is because of
what you can bring to the organization
whether it's your own resource your own
dollars then your contacts your
expertise so to say you know you're not
you're a lawyer but you're not going to
provide any sort of legal assistance is
is really doing the eight
agency a great disservice and it's kind
of surprising how people don't really
sort of put those two together so those
are my top three that a lot of parts to
that and there are more two buttons xr8
gives you sort of a sense of what well
the other one let me just say one pet
peeve I have it's the number of people
who say I'll join the board but I don't
want to raise money I mean that sort of
what you're asked to do but that happens
all the time
don't ask me to ask anybody for money
well that's the way words work well this
evening under the guidance of McKenzie
and company we're all speaking in bullet
points so you had your nine there's a
header three and since I've learned
speaking from Fidel Castro I have 63
points today
but I'll break it into two categories
one is mechanics and the other is
mindset and I suspect the second is the
more important of the two in mechanic's
since I come to this from the point of
view of someone who was the CEO of a
large nonprofit and I've also served on
the boards of large and small
foundations and and community-based
organizations the one thing that has
struck me is most important is
recognizing where you are in the
lifecycle of the organization I'm
getting some feedback most organizations
especially community based organizations
start as volunteer efforts and just as
for-profit enterprise
that if they're successful move from an
entrepreneur an apron Oriole stage to a
mat or organization that requires more
formal management you see nonprofits
moving from infancy through adolescence
to maturity and the shift from a
volunteer or working board to a
governing board or a fundraising board
and is is often a very very difficult
shift and I've I've been in the middle
of that shift I like sometimes to call
the the first stage the bake sale board
and and it's very difficult in a
community-based organization where a lot
of devoted people have spent their time
at that phase to recognize what's needed
on a board as as you as you grow so that
leads into my second bullet point which
is you have to be very clear about what
the board function is you have to tie it
to mission I think you're you're right
bill that the mission of the
organization is frightfully important
and the board function really has to be
tied to that and the board as Susan says
has has to be very clear what's the role
of the CEO and what's the role of the
board because if you're not clear you're
you're headed for trouble and conflict
then how do we how do we get the board
together I think you have to have very
clear criteria for selection and
retention of board members these
criteria have to be tied to the mission
and accomplishing the mission and you
have to think about whether in your
context you need terms or service on the
board whether you need term limits for
service on the board
and what kind of evaluation of the
service of people on the board is is
healthy and necessary about the
California Endowment we actually have a
self-critical system we have self
evaluation every year by the board
members and we have a peer review of all
the board members that's a part of the
process of the nominating committee
deciding where their board members are
going to continue then both Susan and
Bill have have mentioned a point or a
topic that's I think very important and
that's how you structure board meetings
and board participation but everyone in
this room who's been on any kind of a
board has been to a board meeting where
you've got a board book that's three
inches thick and then you have staff
members essentially recite the contents
of the board book back to you leaving
ten minutes at the end of the day or
board discussion and it is either a
conscious or an unconscious way to
render board service absolutely
ineffective so in structuring in board
participation that some of the kinds of
things that I think you should pay
attention to or frequency of meetings
one board I'm on has monthly meetings
and I don't believe busy people can
really commit to monthly meetings so if
I have my way that will change the
agenda on agendas I believe that that
the chair and the CEO are IDI should
pick one or two or maybe three topics
that where they really need the input of
the board and limit discussion to those
with an assumption that any good board
member will have already read in advance
all the materials that are that are
presented in terms of process
I hate split board votes and I because
of what they do to the dynamics of a
group of people serving on the board and
I think that the chair and board
leadership should work on every issue
toward board consensus in my in my time
as CEO of the California Endowment I
never had a a split board vote but that
was because we made very sure that we
didn't trample on the ideas of any
members of the board we work to have
consensus I think that's very important
I also think that it's necessary to
create an environment in which board
members can can mingle with each other
because a lot happens when the meeting
is not is not being in process I was
going to tell you how the bigger board
should be but I've been told by McKenzie
that it doesn't matter so I'm going to
assume
our number my second general topic is is
mindset and under that two general
categories the first is sort of
philosophical or approach and that is
that the most important thing in a
foundation or community-based
organization in my view there are three
of them there focus focus and focus as
an example I will share with you the the
dilemma of the Sonoma land trust where
I'm on the board our our mission is land
preservation and we acquire land in fee
we acquire conservation easements we
have a active stewardship program for
the lands that we own we contract to do
land restoration for state agencies we
do environmental education and we have
been urged from time to time to engage
in low cost housing and political act
advocacy and if we do all those things
when our mission is land preservation we
ain't going to get the land preserved so
it's it's very important as I think bill
was making a point to continue to look
back to your mission and be sure you're
focused on on the mission
another thing that's quite important to
me is is to avoid intellectual incest I
often hear people in the selection of
directors saying we should have them on
the board because they share our values
in in a lot of ways I prefer to have
people who don't share my values I would
like to have
we'll take a different point of view on
on subjects on the board so that you
really can have an exploration of
important issues rather than
automatically knowing when the issue
comes up that everybody on this board is
going to agree on it so I I'm a big fan
of intellectual diversity now there's a
the other mindset issue for me is is
whose money is it anyway
I feel very passionately that once money
gets into a foundation or into a
non-profit it does not belong to the
directors it does not belong to the
staff it belongs to the charitable
beneficiaries and it's too easy to
forget that we've had a lot of examples
in the last year in the nonprofit area
concerns in the land conservation area
with with the deals between the board of
directors and the organization on pieces
of land and I've personally had the
experience of my my salary and benefits
showing up on the front page of the
Sinister San Jose Mercury so I I know
how close it can get fortunately the
other fellow had a bigger salary and a
smaller foundation the so I think there
it's really important in these days to
realize that with the corporate scandals
and the effects of sarbanes-oxley
although they don't
apply to nonprofits that that's that's
the tenor of the world that we're living
in and there's an article in this week's
Forbes as a matter of fact on the
foundation excesses then you're also in
the whose money is it anyway need to
need to have a board that assures that
there are prudent internal controls and
I'll just give you two examples on that
one a CFO not at the California
Endowment who said to me why do we need
an audit don't you trust me and another
which some of you are old enough to
remember in San Francisco some twenty
years ago the executive director of AC T
decided that gold was a good thing to
invest in so he put the entire endowment
of the organization in gold and gold
went down and ASIC a CT almost went out
of existence so it's really important
for directors to to protect the
principle that it ain't their money and
it ain't the staffs money
it belongs to charitable beneficiaries
and they are the trustees of it finally
I will end by saying that I think the
most important thing in in being a
director of a non-profit the most
important things are really personal
characteristics and behavior and and not
the things we've been talking
about before and I I just jotted down
four words one is passion I heard that
word before
another is trust a board doesn't work
unless a personal bonds of trust are
created among the members a third is
candor it doesn't work if what's said in
the board room is different from what
said out in the hall outside the
boardroom and finally I will close with
the fact that successful board requires
respect for diverse ideas thank you
thanks Lou Jackie okay
my favorite ESOP fable is trying to
describe the elephant and I'm sure most
of you know this but one is feeling just
silence oh very much like a rock the
other one's got hold of his leg and said
no no it's very much like a tree of
course the other one has a trunk and
says oh no it's like a snake now they
were all right and I think that
organizations are somewhat like that I
think that organizations are perceived
and described by wherever in your
contact is and it's different for the
participants in the organization and for
the board members in the organization
and for the executive director of an
organization and this is one of the
reasons why one of those critical
relationships and challenging
relationships in an organization is that
between the executive director or CEO in
that board of directors they have to be
partners or you cannot implement the
vision of the organization and its goals
in bills point-three hear about roles
and responsibilities this is true in
relationship to the executive director
as well as in relationship to the board
itself and in an oversimplified but true
statement you might say that the board
is in charge of policy and the executive
director
CEO is in charge of implementing that
policy but it's a lot more complicated
than that
also number four about having to have
clear structure and expectations that
too is a true part an executive director
or CEO as well as for board members you
get into real big trouble when the staff
executive is moving independently from
and forward without the support and
without the interaction with policy but
you also get into big trouble when the
board members get too involved in the
management and the administration of the
organization and get involved in
micromanagement some of those key issues
that tend to be conflict areas are
usually around the issues of money and a
personnel and when you get into those
conflicts it's difficult to have a
negotiation effective between difference
of opinion with the executive director
and the board because reality is every
wise executive directed City knows that
the power is in the board of directors
they are the authority of the
organization they are the legal
authority of the organization and in the
principles of mediation and negotiation
we know that one of the principles that
is required is parody of power and yet
we don't really have parody of power
between those two entities but there's
got to be a a way in which that is
balanced out so that the board and the
executive can work in a in a true
partnership and this is somewhat
complicated by the fact that all of us
wear so many hats I serve on boards I'm
currently president of a board my board
members our CEOs in Edy's as well as
being board members and this is pretty
true in the nonprofit world particularly
my type of organization so that when you
try to make those distinctions between
policy issues and implementation issues
you got to think which hat you're
wearing at the moment because in this
situation your executive director
another situation you might be a board
member so these things tend to make life
okay and I believe in a paradox and in
having to be able to embrace multiple
truths that seem contradictory you have
a scene out there and different people
looking through different windows at the
same scene are going to see different
things and out of that you you get a
different perception about what the
problem is and what the solution might
be I've been the executive director of
two new organizations where I was the
founding or the initial director I have
been the director of two old
organizations and one in between my
present organizations YMCA Volkman
is a hundred and twenty-five years old
this year so you know your cycles that
you go through there's also a big
difference in working with an
organization with the traditions of the
YWCA of Oakland which was the first west
of Mississippi and so forth and in a
Julie Morgan building and all that good
stuff very different from the brand new
small organization and as an executive
director the values that I would look
for and you do have some influence and
choosing the board members but you don't
really choose the board members but you
do have some influence from time to time
and those things that I would value
first of all that they have a passion
for the mission that they not only
understand the mission but that they
have a passion for the mission secondly
I value a positive attitude I mean I
want to board this made up mostly have
full cups and not half empty cups and
you need to keep that positive energy
going right now my president board
cheerleader is Renee who's a media
person and she's just wonderful and
she's at that meeting you're going to
have a positive atmosphere the second is
respect and that's a part of trust and
that is absolutely essential to contain
diversity in an organization and I'm
talking about all kinds of diversity age
cultural ethnic and
economics skills and etcetera and there
I think about the president of my board
of directors in Washington at the day
can Child Development Council Americans
Jack me man who was president Bank
Street College and this man just just
you know that just radiates out of him
and he was able as a board president to
always manage it so that respect was
always on the ground floor the other
thing I value is balance I think you
have to have a good balance between
caution and risk-taking there's a time
when you just got to go for it and with
the organization other why do we see of
Oakland went through a major crisis and
almost went under with problems with the
rebuild at the building after the Loma
Prieta earthquake and you've got to have
you got to be willing to let go
sometimes your caution and just go
farther you're loose ball game also
you've got to have balances between
being serious and having fun and I think
of my boyfriend with y'all ago solace
who says it's not fun I'm not going to
do it and I think that one of the things
that the seat of the executive director
plays a major role in is how fun it is
for these people to get together and to
be able to plan so that you can enjoy
what you're doing because they're not a
lot it's hard work and not a lot of
rewards in the nonprofit community if
you're not having fun it's hard to keep
doing it I also value water for
breakfast you've got the right mix of
what I would kind of work horses and
show horses you got to have outstanding
people in the community that will need a
visible recognition but you got to have
those were questions and I try every
chance I get to pair them up because you
just you know you need both of them
going together finally the bottom line
for me is that I want a board to work
with the board that helps me and I can
help them stay out of get out of and
stay out of what I call the W family and
that is the one don't worry in wine when
organizations in trouble it is so easy
to stay in that room of the wonder we're
in wine and I'm sure that we don't have
to even talk about the many ways that
you manifest itself you got to get out
of there
a family which is a firm assess and act
and actually that's so important to me
now that when I start worrying about
problems in the middle of the night I
actually start doing that month mantra
affirm assess and act and it's become
clear to me that you have to affirm
first when you're dealing with difficult
problems you got to affirm that you've
dealt with more difficult problems
Eadie's and CEOs need the boy to affirm
them and the good things that they're
doing before they get in on the subject
of the things that are not going so well
but once you affirm and then you assess
and then you're able to act and stay in
that mode and that's really the bottom
line for me and that's what my growth is
as an executive director and working
with the board of directors to achieve
about come ago